Hannah and told Peter to leave Madison
came back and bar space watched it all
and Peter is still in love with Madison
she's still in love with him and there's
Barb's face again everybody here we go
we had the bachelor finale
[Music]
you guys thank you so much for tuning in
i'm lauren zima we just watched the
bachelor finale and you know we could
have called it the barber finale I'm
going to get some champagne going but
this is the saddest champagne isn't it
it sure is I'm gonna tell our control
room I can hear this music playing in my
ear and it's very difficult so if
there's any way to kill it that would be
great
did did barb kill it Wow here we are
everybody I am taking your comments and
questions alive so send them through on
youtube on our Instagram and I'm gonna
get them here on this iPad as we talk
through and process together what was
I'm gonna go ahead and say it definitely
one of the top-five wildest bachelor
finales that there has ever been
do you disagree do you agree let me know
in the comments below are you a team a
center team barb I don't like pitting
women or people against each other but
those two are not on the same page are
they let's get to it please drink
responsibly god it's the saddest
champagne it's so wild alright everybody
so first of all let's just talk about
the big moments of the night and then
we're gonna go through everything that
we saw barb and Madison had a massive
showdown after we found out that Madison
and Peter we're still in love with each
other and I want to point out that this
is after Madison broke up with Peter and
then a Peter proposed to Hannah and he
didn't tell her that Madison had broken
up with him and she would later tell him
that that really was kind of blindsiding
and unfair because she wasn't totally
clued in on everything so that's where
things ratna Peter broke up with Hannah
and she said oh honey just leave she had
a really wonderful like strong woman
moment really put on his place about how
you should say words that you mean and
your words don't have any weight if you
don't put any meaning behind them and so
they broke up then they kind of seemed
fine cuz they walked away holding hands
and then so Peter then went back to LA
and then Chris Harrison went to Alabama
and he
got Madison and then Madison said you
know what I do want a second chance
never then then in top they talked for
the first time here on the stage tonight
so they talked to each other and they
said they're so in love with each other
and Barb said no thanks to that let's
take a look here's barb oh maybe we
don't have a shot yet we don't have barb
we don't have barb I want everybody to
process that we don't have barb oh wow
all right so we'll bring bar back in a
moment but barb told everybody that she
just simply didn't think that Peter and
Madison's relationship would work so
what did you guys think while we are
doing that I'm going to go ahead and get
some of your questions coming through
let's see if we can pull up the barb
clip and we'll begin with your comments
Oh Maura what are your thoughts on the
barb madison thing all right I'll just
tell you guys my thoughts right now I
think that barb is coming from a place
of love with her son as she said and you
know what I got to give Barb and Madison
both props because they're both standing
true on how they feel Madison says it's
my journey to I said what I wanted to
say and I'm going at this with you know
how I feel about it and barb said well I
don't feel like you really love my son
and I don't feel this is gonna work Wow
do we have the clip yet we're still
working on it okay so let's take it back
then for now we are going to go back to
the big reveal which we finally got so
we had been teased all season long that
Peter was going to nearly pass out when
he learned something in Australia and it
was that we weren't sure Hannah was
going to show up take a listen
yeah so that's Chris Harrison saying
we're not sure if Hannah Ann's gonna
make it and you know what that took a
turn real quick didn't that life comes
at you fast we then found out that
Hannah Anne
was on her way so and in the time of a
commercial break I guess decided nope
she's gonna go she's stuck by Peters
side through all this and she was gonna
keep doing it and then Peter went ahead
and didn't even really question well why
did she think about not coming I'll
Chris Harrison took his jacket off for
this conversation I missed that on the
first watch
Peter didn't seem to ask a lot of
questions instead he just wanted to ask
one question to Hanna and he proposed
take a listen
my heart was being torn in two different
directions
- now I have to follow my heart so
Madison
she actually left two days ago
and I am here beautiful spirit is
honestly like anything I have ever seen
before
yeah it's a nice when somebody proposes
and they bring up another woman in the
proposal what did you guys think of that
oh it was worrisome from the start
wasn't it because yes Peter was saying
that Hannah hands the most beautiful
spirit and yes he was saying but his
heart was 100% with her which we would
later find out it wasn't but he was also
saying Madison's name and I understand
that the show is set up so that you date
multiple people and I've even critiqued
Madison for like having a problem with
that but I have to say that in the
proposal moment you shouldn't be talking
about other people you know and it was a
red flag wasn't it so many red flags
that we've ignored all season haven't we
yeah all right so they get engaged and
we find out of course how much barb
loves Hannah and I did a quick poll on
Twitter to ask everybody who was more
excited for Peter and Hannah Ann's
engagement Peter and Hannah ant or barb
barb one lancelot so barb starts crying
right away we knew we'd see more of barb
crying and she starts crying the second
that Peter walks in to tell her how
everything is gone she's saying she
missed his smile she missed his hellos
Peter's father noted it had been just
just a week since they've seen him but
you know maybe Peter is a really special
way of saying hello God she loves her
son doesn't she I will say to be loved
on this level to be loved by the liked
by anybody like this it's a beautiful
thing
beautiful complicated dramatic messy
dark gorgeous wonderful chilling thing
so then Peter tells his mom that he went
with what she said he went with her pick
he proposed to Hannah and and they are
engaged who is it she said who is it I
thought Peter might kill barb
accidentally in this moment she she was
really on the edge of her seat and oh
there she goes she's fine
so Barb's so excited about Hanna Ann
right couldn't be happier and Peter had
done what mom had told him to do she had
said pick Hanna and it's in God's plan I
said a prayer this is what I want so we
did it and it didn't surprise me guys
were you surprised
I interviewed Peter back in September I
posted this interview on my Instagram
earlier and I'd forgotten that that I
kind of noticed then I said Peter I
don't think you're gonna pick somebody
your parents don't approve of and not if
I'm directly quoting him I believe you
said definitely not that's what happened
but here we are so Peter and Hannah Ann
are engaged but just like Hannah and
decided to come and show up to the
proposal real quick after debating it
Peter would do a quick turn on his
decision to get engaged to Hannah and we
see Hannah and visit Peter and this is
you know probably supposed to be one of
their happy couple weekends but the
second she walked in you could tell
something was off couldn't she like
their energy was pretty dark and you
know what else I noticed Sky's gray
colored couch that's what they're
sitting on and that triggered me right
back to re lion Dyke jr. breaking up
with Becca kufran on a gray couch and
look at Barb's face barb in the box
during this finale is one of the most
beautiful and unbelievable choices I've
ever seen on television and if this show
doesn't finally win an Emmy just for
barb in the box
cheers to barb in the box and by the way
don't drink every time you saw barb in
the box mm-hmm
we saw barb giving stone cold face we
saw barb applauding her son getting
slammed and we saw barb when he got back
with Madison and it was quite a lot
wasn't it we're gonna get to it
so here's what Peter tells Hannah and
after he tells her that he's been
struggling in their relationship take a
listen
like I want so badly to be able to give
you everything give you my entire heart
what you do to me that's everything you
deserve I can't do that I can't do it
give her everything just said when he
proposed
that she had 100% of his heart went
blasts it had been a while since we've
gotten whiplash on this season but it's
coming in hot dad puts Peter in his
place so quickly you guys I want to pour
a drink and I want to stand a Hannah Ann
because she used every moment on our
televisions tonight to be strong to make
herself known and to tell Peter what he
was missing out on didn't she
listen to what Hannah and said to him
when he said this was a mistake
[Music]
you took that away from me
cuz I trusted you and that's what you
have continued to ask me to do yep
mm-hmm
remember when Hannah Ann's dad told her
not to waste a word while she did not
waste a word tonight did she no she did
not
it was interesting that she said you
took away my first engagement like I
just thought that wording was funny
are you planning on more or did she just
like already have the wherewithal that
in that moment this is my first now's
not gonna have a second you're gonna get
a second girl don't worry I hope to see
Hannah Hannah in paradise to you let me
know in the comments below
oh your comments I should get back to
those okay I'm so sorry everybody I'm so
into what's happening let me open up our
iPad and Oh Sally do you think Madison
and Peter will actually last well Peters
parents don't they straight-up said that
on the finale they said this isn't gonna
work dad said they had too many
obstacles and Mama Barb said all of
their friends and family you know Peter
think this isn't gonna work so I will
say that I think it's quite a strong
indicator that the two people who raised
this man don't think it's gonna work
however I will say that you know what
I'm not one to squash love if two people
want it I think if Peter and Madison
want to make it work and they want to
try then I support them as they try but
I don't know I do all
so fundamentally agree with his parents
with what they said last night but it's
very difficult to embark on a
relationship when two people have really
fundamental worldviews that are
different and here's another thing
people can change people can become more
like others if they want to be but I
haven't heard Peters say he wants to
change his ways for Madison I haven't
heard Madison says she wants to change
her ways for Peter and they have
fundamentally very different ways with
faith with socializing big stuff so we
shall see but I raise a glass in the
name of positivity if it's what should
be how about when Peter said or when I
Hannah and said that Peter reached out
to Hannah be okay I love it all so much
so hidden put Peter in his place she
goes to the bathroom just like Becca
kufran did when Ari told her he was
gonna be going after his runner-up
Lauren Lyon Dyke and by the way they are
now married and happily have a baby so
you know who knows she goes to the
bathroom she did not lock Peter out
Peter followed her and Hannah and she
holds up that ring and she delivers just
beautiful prose and puts him in his
place and what was totally wild about it
was that as Hannigan was holding up the
ring to Peter
barb was in the box and barb was
applauding her son getting broken up
with she was cheers in Hannah and on as
Hannah Ann told Peter that she was done
with him
barb is just clap clap clapping away in
that box I think we have that clip we
should Hannah Ann's done and barb is
clapping in the name of the break-up
with her son let's take a look I don't
need anything more from you
you've done enough damage
I'm done here you go here's this
plotting oh wow
what'd you guys think of that let me
know in the comments below Wow
so Hannah Ann tells Peter to leave and
then we find out you know now Peter
single Hannah and single and I guess
Madison is single because Chris Harrison
takes a little ride of his own huh in
just a minute
now Peter does tell Chris that he admits
that his feelings for Madison were part
of the break-up and Wow Wow Wow barbs
face when he said that you know
everybody I'm just good ol barb her eyes
were just cutting holes to me how about
Barb's glam as well I think Chicago hair
cut her hair looks ol darker
everything's darker isn't it I just want
to take a moment to hold up our graphic
and say don't drink every time you saw
Barb's face tonight and every time those
eyes cut through your soul okay so Hanna
Anna's gonna come out and talk to Peter
and she again does not mess around in
the hot seat she keeps things spicy
here's what she said those were you know
words are powerful Peter yeah that
wasn't the entire clip but she said
words are powerful and they have weight
and meaning and I just want to applaud
because this is Peter the 747 is a heavy
plane mm-hmm-hmm and things are
turbulent if you're not flying smooth
with those big words Peter okay so
cheers to Hannah and Hannah Anne tells
him that he downplayed the Madison thing
when he proposed I agree and that she
felt blindsided and then she tells him
how to be a real man take a listen the
first red flag that you gave to me was
when you wanted to reach out to Anna
Brown to find closure with her so really
looking back on it our engagement
involved three women
me you still being in love with Madison
and proposing to me and you need
enclosure with Hannah brown that's three
women involved in our engagement that
was completely blindsided too so word of
advice if you want to be with a woman
you need to become a real man she told
him to become a real man she told
everyone that he had reached out to
Hannah Brown during their engagement
form or closure course at champagne for
WoW but I do want to I have to say raise
a glass to Peter because as I said
during the woman's hello and as I always
say all you can do is own what you've
done atone for it if necessary and grow
from there and Peter did say that he was
wrong he said that he was sorry and he
said he's gonna try to be better so
Peter we love you we support you oh hi
Anna Ann how did you feel she did I'm
gonna tell all I'm gonna tell the finale
after the final rose where are we let me
know in the comments below okay so Chris
Harrison is gonna take a trip over to
Alabama he's been there a lot the past
couple years and he is going to tell
Madison what has happened to take a
listen the reason I'm here today is to
give you news Peter is single he ended
his engagement with Hannah yeah Wow and
then you know what I'm just gonna say
let's listen what Madison had to say to
that
here she is about a second chance I
think in his dream he would be with you
um
[Music]
like shaking
I mean yeah we had a second chance at
this like you know I'd take an RV I do
want to raise a glass to Madison because
something I loved and that gave me some
faith in her and Peter's relationship is
that when Peter when she found out Peter
was single her first response was is he
okay and you know what I I thought that
was open-hearted and loving and it made
me think this plane you made me think
that she does care about Peter because
you know that was her first reaction was
just is he alright how is he it wasn't
about her so cheers to Madison for that
now before we get into the real meat of
it all let me take a few more of your
questions Clarissa says where has this
version of Hannah Ann been all season
that's a great question I do think that
sometimes this show and this experience
puts people in a bit of a bachelor
bubble and that they get a little bit
outside of themselves and especially
when you're younger that can happen so I
don't know also maybe Hannah and just
grew from this whole experience I feel
like we saw growth and strength Laura
and I says what do you think about Kelly
being there I think that Kelly was there
to throw us off Kelly Flanagan I think
that's why she was in the audience
because some people thought that maybe
her and Peter were together in the end
obviously not Kelly didn't even say a
word she wasn't if her tell-all
it seems who from this season will end
up on VIP and do you think Hannah Ann
should have been the Bachelorette from
Zak and Michael gosh I will say that
Hannah Ann really held her own tonight
and maybe if we hadn't already learned
about our Bachelorette being clear
Crawley which I'm very excited about
I am the maybe it could have been her
but I do just like that the show is
doing something different that we're
going with a woman in her late 30s and
Hank Claire's been on this franchise for
five years maybe in a couple years
Hannah hands Bachelorette okay anything
could happen
as we learned tonight right yeah all
right so let's get to it Madison walks
out into the studio and she sits down
with Peter and Peter and Madison both
reveal oh I'm sorry this is Madison
walking out into a random house and
la and she talks to Peter and AH Peters
shocked to see her he's surprised
Barb's still making that face but it
let's now go to the studio
Madison walks out and sits with me and
they say that they are taking things one
step at a time and Peter says that's
they're together and that one day at a
time is probably the smartest way to go
he says and I quote do we have a million
obstacles yeah he says and I quote is it
all uphill probably don't drink every
time Peter wants not easy but crazy and
don't take me as saying that Madison's
crazy I'm not saying that saying their
relationships a lot of ups and downs and
it has been oh so barb he's now gonna
get her moment we find out that Peter
and Madison both love each other and
they're gonna try this well guess what
barb barb doesn't want anybody to try
her right now
I was shocked you guys I thought the
barb might come in all this with a bit
more sensitivity you know at first she
was saying look Hannah Ann was more in
love with Peter so that's why I embraced
her more but no no no
then bara Blade things on the line she
explained that day when she met Madison
she said she had to wait for Madison for
three hours
ding every time barb said three hours
because she had us wait three hours for
her to come in so we were there three
hours we had just come across the
country and we had to wait three hours
and when she did come in
Wow yep
a three-hour get me off of this tour
that's what barb said so barb laid into
a lead into Madison didn't she and Chris
Harrison said to her and her husband
Peter senior what do you think is gonna
happen from here and barb said and I
quote he's gonna have to fail to succeed
let's listen to barb
everybody exceed that's it Chris all his
friends and all his friends all his
family everyone that knows him knows
that it's it's not you know it's not
gonna work
so we've been it's not gonna work barb
says according to all of Peters friends
and family you guys this show is the
gift that keeps on giving and I don't
mean that I'm here to relish in
anybody's pain but remember when they
promised us that this finale would be
unlike any other unprecedented that we
wouldn't know how it ended well they
delivered oh my goodness we have never
had a moment like that
with a parent and a lead before what do
you guys think
how will Peter and Madison move forward
from here how do you move forward when
all of America knows that somebody's
family doesn't want you dating them yeah
I mean look again I think Madison held
her own
I don't think Madison's an evil person I
don't think barb is an evil person I
just think that barb and Peter senior
feel that this is not going to work out
for their son and do I think barb was a
little over the top with her emotions
for Peter a little too pushy she should
let him figure this out on her own yes I
do I do if only for Barb's sake so that
Peter wouldn't ever hold any of this
against her later but this is where we
are gonna take a few more of your
comments and then we are going to wrap
things up oh yes do you think Peter
needs to go to a cardiologist because
his heartbeat and need for love is
concerning Jess not a bad point I want
to cheers to whoever was putting all
those heartbeats in this episode
wild and Nicole says did barb forget how
much she loved Madison the first time
they met Wow
interesting interesting this whole
season has been whipped last you guys
things have changed we haven't known who
frontrunners are the ending changed we
didn't know what was going to happen and
what a season it has been I have of
course loved everything about doing
roses and roses a here with you guys and
here's the thing this finale has been so
unprecedented so wild then we're gonna
need a full and complete roses and roses
a breakdown of it all right so next
Tuesday per usual we're putting up a
roses and Rose a we are going to give
you a full video going over both nights
of the finale and referencing things
back from the entire season of The
Bachelor because what a ride it's been
so next Tuesday as usual you will have
an episode of roses and roses a
everybody and that's not a 747 I'm not
just saying that I'm gonna my word just
have weight it's really gonna be there
the episode Tuesday so be there I love
you guys so much thank you for watching
I am on Twitter and Instagram follow me
there and we will be doing roses and
Rosie for all the bachelor franchise
shows listen your heart is coming up so
don't fret everybody listen to your
heart into your heartbeat listen to your
heart and maybe your mom's advice I
don't know it's up to you I love you
guys so much again next Tuesday a new
episode of roses in rows eight covering
it all and tomorrow and Entertainment
Tonight Chris Harrison is joining me to
go over everything that happened in this
wild live finale I love you all so much
and let me just say wait for it wait for
it until next Tuesday
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]